welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is Helen sue a professor of anthropology
her teaching interests are political and
historical anthropology and urban and
global culture change for the past four
decades professor su has explored the
nature of the socialist state and the
refashioning of identities in South
China more recently she is researching
the rural-urban divide in china
cross-border dynamics in hong kong and
historical and contemporary asian
connections today we'll talk with
Professor see you about China's urban
revolution welcome professor CEO thank
you you have spent a good number of
years doing research in China let's
begin with an overview of the work that
you've done well forty years yes I
started I started working on China in
the mid-70s when I was a graduate
student China of course is a constantly
moving target in the 70s I was in the
countryside studying the impact of the
rural revolution in the 80s when the
Chinese government decided to liberalize
its economy I followed a lot of the
young migrant workers into the market
towns and to study basically to explore
the development of redevelopment of
trade the the rising of the small-scale
enterprises and then the refashioning of
cultural identities but by the 90s the
government was privatizing the urban
economy and housing and allowed huge
numbers of rural migrants into the
cities to look for work and so I
followed the 100 million plus rural
migrants into the Chinese cities and you
actually see the the urban landscape
changing together with a rising urban
middle-class consumers and so today I
went further and followed her and have
been following the very adventurous
entrepreneurs in China to the Middle
East and to Africa because they they
have been responding to the call of the
Chinese government to go out to the
world as Oh to speak so in a sense to
summarize I mean these 40 years to me
china is a moving target and I study
China not as a place but as a process so
wherever you know at certain crucial
historical junctures when you know
certain cultural political dynamics you
know have been exciting that's where I
have nice let's talk about some of the
major changes you've been able to
witness over the course of those 40
years the major changes well if I have
to say in the 70s when I was in shock
when i went to china in the mid-70s
everything was red but life was
colorless and by ready main communist
political ethically ya know it was the
height of the Maoist period and so so it
was then very bare and life was bare
colorless because today after 35 40
years of economic reforms things have
changed about and you can see a whole
country just on the fast-forward mode
everybody's is desperately trying to
catch up with the world after decades of
deprivation material deprivation but you
also see some very conflicting
sentiments like what you see very
lingering social you know feelings of
lingering socialist entitlements but
coupled with some you know some firm
belief in the survival of the fittest
and also our believe in this sort of
naked market forces
so you see a lot of these things
happening Oh at the same time so but
life is extremely files are fast-paced
ëthis is there still a sense of that
redness that you spoke of earlier it
surely is and and I've written on it
quite a bit since the mid-90s actually
because the redness actually hasn't got
hasn't been obviously it's is lingering
it's lingering and it's I think it has
to do with several generations of of
Chinese citizens having internalized in
the power of the state and so you still
see the the you know ever the state very
very dominant in everyday life and so
and and it affects people even people
who who who are so determined to put the
revolution behind them and yet the
moment they open their mouth is still
the language of the state very so I
called that state involution okay and
how about surprises have you come across
a new surprises over the course of your
work there anything is in wow I didn't
see that car hanger well surprises not
really but paradoxes yes okay let's talk
about that and since we're going to talk
about the urban revolution so i will
pick that up as an example of course
today every the whole world would see
that China's cities artists booming
everywhere of course you have ghost
cities and a hundred of them or whatever
but for most of the very important
cities particularly along the coast you
see things thriving and in the the
intensity the scale and the audacity of
city building means that in China many
of these cities are running out of space
the officials you know for their vanity
or whatever our building landmarks
spectacular landmarks and infrastructure
the rising middle class are also
looking for space for their gated
communities for shopping malls for parks
for museums whenever to build up their
cultural capital migrants flooding into
the cities as I said there's a hundred
million plus people working in factories
working in markets and building
infrastructure and they are sort of
crammed in these cheap housing at the
margins then know if the cities are
spreading you have they have to spread
somewhere and so the villages on the
edges on the margins of these cities are
facing an urban tsunami so there are
still villages versus towns and cities
that we would call here there's quite a
disparity between the two yes yes
because particularly you know villages
are basically from the Maoist revolution
days the villages are collectives and so
what's happening with this rural urban
interface at this point when cities are
spreading is that you see the villages
trying to protect themselves now the
city's the city officials particularly
but look at these villages as you know
you know primitive backward you know
dirty or even you know chaotic illegible
and so they would target a lot of these
villages for demolition even though that
was part of their history mm-hmm it's
interesting yeah oh yeah because but the
city of issues I mean they're desperate
to to have space because real estate and
land development now has become the
major source of their budget and so they
have to expand but that's the only way
to expand right and so what happened is
that the villages even though they're
being targeted as these urban enclaves
surrounded by Moors and gated
communities and whatever they dig in
their heels and they cling onto their
rural statuses they cling onto their
cultural traditions and village cultural
traditions and they are bargaining for
state compensation
and they also gaming the Big Time real
estate so so in a sense you see that
these tensions very hotly contested
areas and this rural urban divide and so
long as cities are expanding out width I
think these volatilities are going to
continue for a while so are there any
major violent kinds of uprisings yes
it's we just don't hear it in the media
I was going to say I have been about
that even main mainstream Western media
has been reporting I mean from York
Times to the Guardian tool to all over
the world but you you pick a lot of that
from the blogs and from from you know
sort of news channels that's that's gone
over the firewall of the Chinese media
is ours yeah there's a lot of them yeah
so earlier you had mentioned following
Chinese out into the world and in Africa
and the Middle East so currently it
strikes me as here is a bit of a I call
it a scramble for africa harkening back
to the colonial Scramble for Africa
taking place there now I'm curious to
know your perceptions of how China is
shaping Africa for instance it's a very
very hot topic China Africa today well a
few years ago as I was studying the the
urban village enclaves in Guangzhou or
cantonal you know in opening I was
already noticing a large number of West
African traders in Guangzhou a whole
class you know they are living in these
cheap housing in these urban villages
and I was wondering who they who they
were they were they basically West
Africans from Nigeria garner Ivory Coast
senegal Molly even Angola and the
francophone Anglophone they're Muslims
and they're Christians and at the height
of it even in one city of Nome in
Guangzhou there's like about I was told
about 100
thousand of them so there's a huge
number within the city space and so I
was wondering what's happening but of
course in Hong Kong there's always been
though chongqing mentioned the infamous
chongqing mentioned where all these
African traders were trading and
ordering goods to be sold back to Africa
so it's kind of a low low end
globalization according to a colleague
of mine Gordon Matthews anyway and so as
I was just noticing that my colleagues
who worked on Africa have also been
noticing that there's a chinese
everywhere in the african continent so
we decided in a Mike McGovern and a
junior colleague mine at the time and I
we decided to form a small research
cluster with our PhD students and then
we went to China to take a look so we
went to Guangzhou we went to emu south
of Shanghai to see where these Africans
and Arab traders to you know have been
congregating and then last year we also
went to tanzania and zanzibar so in a
sense we're trying to understand what's
happening on the ground and for
anthropologists and historians we are
particularly trained to capture with
knowledge local knowledge with languages
and with in our observations on the
ground we hope to cut through or a
cutaway may be the kind of geopolitical
polemics to portray china either as
friend or ask colonizing so we really
need that kind of sophisticated you know
nuanced local knowledge and that's what
we do best so what what are you finding
from the work you're doing in Africa how
have the Chinese affected Africa in any
substantial way well I think in two
thousand eight or 2009 I forgot when one
of these years China already overtook
the US
as the biggest investor in the continent
so the investment is huge and you know
what they're investing and particularly
yeah mainly infrastructure I mean the
Chinese are building everything I mean
roads ports airports railroads our
houses everything so but it's still very
much hardware relatively less has been
done in building up software for human
or social development if you see the
supposedly a million Chinese workers
they're already in the continent I was
told as a millennia I don't have two
figures but you know at least you see
them everywhere but then they are very
much living in company camps and then
the interaction with local society is
quite minimal that's what I was going to
ask if there was any interaction yes
basically they keep them yeah they sell
to themselves I mean there you can grow
their own food I mean it's really quite
surprising of course language is a
barrier their salaries aren't even paid
their their salaries are paid via banks
in their home you know villages or towns
in China and so that kind of cultural
barrier you know I think whenever you
know these kind of misunderstandings can
really become very politicized so that's
so much strikes me as it might be a very
good opportunity for some Chinese
especially the people on the fringes to
go to Africa for a better job per se or
is that what you're finding I think you
know I I have a doctoral student who
just finished her to station on migrants
children that is already a younger
generation of migrant workers you know
beyond you know their parents generation
who contributed to China as well factory
now I can see that a younger generation
of more adventurous migrant workers are
going abroad and trying to find
in your livelihood so it's but the
problem still is that they they are
keeping to themselves and they're coming
from particular regions so it's quite
structured yeah that's interesting let's
move on to the new work you are
embarking on the inter Asia initiative
with the generous funding you received
from the Carnegie corporate corporation
give us an overview of what you're doing
with that project and what you hope to
accomplish I think well that's just
another intellectual baby of mine and I
suppose I have to backtrack a little bit
just to give a contact sure about 12
years ago I was you know I i finished
chairing the East Asian Council and
doing other things and I was already
noticing even then you know that's in
the late late 1990s I already noticed
that the center of gravity of Asian
Studies was moving to Asia and so I
figured that we need a base there okay I
mean it of course it's been monopolized
by the US and Europe quite a bit in
terms of asian studies but so i set up
an interdisciplinary and inter-regional
research institute there is a very
modest little thing but it's creative is
strategic you know I always think of it
as a mini you know it's small is
flexible is strategic but it has a BMW
engine right sir but anyway and so I
started that and and by you know for a
long time we were focusing on training
up postgraduate students and also
exposing our junior faculty to things
asia but by 2006 I was already noticing
that the whole world was being sucked
into China so I decided to take all our
critical mass and move the opposite
direction and so we started this
interracial agenda so quite a bit you
know a hit you know i would say quite
the head of some of our peers and at the
same time ssrc that is social science we
should research council which remains a
very very core partner here you know um
they organized a big conference in Dubai
2008 and from then on we we hoped we
have a very good partnership with them
with national Singapore University and
then also with the Hong Kong Institute
for humanities and Social Sciences which
I established no 12 years ago in Hong
Kong and so the three of us have been
holding conferences creating interracia
focus mcmillan center came in here in
Shapiro and Nancy Luther kindly gave me
a little bit of of seed money to keep
Yale in the picture okay but most of the
funds came from you know the three
partners in so we've been working on
that and we had conferences two by two
thousand eight and then Singapore 2010
in Hong Kong 2012 and then this coming
for we're going to have another one in
in Istanbul and what will that
interracia about six to eight Khan sort
of simultaneous panels each having about
12 speakers and paper givers and we
solicited a paper proposals all over the
world I mean it's a tremendous network
and every time we get about 80 to a
hundred hundred and twenty even
participants so you really see a
critical community growing with a
certain agenda to do two things one to
rethink the land-based state centered
you know rather static social science
paradigms and to rethink that and then
converting that into processes you know
processes over land sea air and even
title from cyberspace and so we are we
thinking regional studies we rethinking
globalization in historical and
contemporary terms so so it's growing
and and now with the Carnegie fun coming
in this year we are actually creating
more digital networks and we are turning
our attention to curriculum building and
also teaching and the training of
postdocs and so hopefully with with all
the partners coming in and yayo now
being one of our core partners in this
venture you know we will we will hope
that more people will join us and if we
run all of this with a very small budget
most of the funds you know for these
interracial research clusters are still
being funded by my Institute in Hong
Kong but we are getting you know funds
elsewhere and so there's more and more
interest yeah yeah in the interest just
like the china-africa our venture I mean
the interest has been quite overwhelming
I mean you know nicely a overwhelming
but we've we've done it with a
shoestring budget but with lots and lots
of goodwill and lots and lots of team
spirit so I think that's what we do so
we have more to look forward to through
that project yeah so okay well thank you
so much for being here today and sharing
some of your work so thank you very much
for inviting me for more information
about professors hue and her research
please visit our website at yale edu
slash mcmillan report be sure to join us
again for another episode of the
macmillan report made possible through
funding from the Whitney and Betty
Macmillan Center for International and
area studies at Yale
you